- Son nom est assez méconnu ici,
mais il était pourtant un soldat
d'exception et un tireur
d'élite. Certains le surnomment
même le Rambo québécois.
Léo Major s'est illustré lors
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
qui s'est officiellement
terminée le 2 septembre 1945.
76 ans plus tard,
jour pour jour, une cérémonie
commémorative s'est tenue
à Longueuil, dans un parc
qui porte son nom.
DANIEL-AIMÉ MAJOR,
fils de Léo Major
- C'est un grand honneur
qu'on lui fait en ce moment, un
honneur je pense qu'il mérite.
- C'est aux Pays-Bas
qu'il a réalisé son principal
fait d'armes en libérant seul
une ville de 50 000 habitants,
Zwolle, de l'occupation nazie
en faisant croire aux troupes
allemandes que les Canadiens
s'apprêtent à attaquer.
LUC LÉPINE, historien militaire
- Léo, avec deux mitraillettes
et 15 grenades, va être capable
d'expulser les Allemands
de la ville et sauver tous
les habitants qui auraient
été pilonnés.
- L'impact est tel qu'encore
aujourd'hui, les Pays-Bas
commémorent ce héros de guerre.
- Depuis 1970, aux Pays-Bas,
à tous les ans, il y a une fête
pour Léo Major, au moment
de la libération de la ville
de Zwolle : toutes les écoles
font des concours où
ils écrivent des textes sur
Léo Major, il y a même presque
un hymne national sur Léo Major.
- L'homme était humble
et discret; les proches de Léo
Major n'ont appris ses exploits
que des années plus tard.
- C'était la première fois que
ma femme savait ce que j'avais
fait durant la guerre.
Je ne lui en avais jamais parlé.
Dans ce temps-là, je ne parlais
pas du tout.
- On le considère comme
un humaniste, guidé par
les principes d'éthique
et de justice.
- Il a toujours été là pour
la liberté des gens et je pense
que s'il devait recommencer
aujourd'hui, il le ferait
s'il était là.
- Si les accomplissements
de Léo Major demeurent méconnus
du public, ils ont néanmoins été
soulignés par François Legault
lors du 75e anniversaire
du débarquement de Normandie.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Tout seul, il a réussi
à libérer une ville de 50 000
habitants. Quand vous allez
en Hollande et que vous parlez
de Léo Major, c'est encore
un héros.
- Et sa vie, digne d'un film
ou d'un livre d'histoire,
est désormais mise en lumière
à Longueuil pour qu'il ne tombe
plus jamais dans l'oubli.
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.